Hey Thoughty2 here.
On average, 12 newborns will be given to the
wrong parents daily.
Welcome to RIF.
1.
The limbo world record is just 6 inches high.
2.
1 in every 4 Americans has appeared on TV.
3.
Johnny Cash's estate was approached by an
advertising company asking for permission
to use Ring Of Fire on an ad for haemorrhoid
cream.
The request was refused.
4.
In the Durango desert, in Mexico, there's
a creepy spot called the "Zone of Silence."
You can't pick up clear TV or radio signals.
And locals say fireballs sometimes appear
in the sky.
5.
Every year about 98% of atoms in your body
are replaced.
6.
As a punishment for misbehavior, Thai cops
have to wear pink Hello Kitty armbands.
7.
If the population of China walked past you
in single file, the line would never end.
Because of their rate of reproduction.
8.
The Bible is the number one most shoplifted
book of all time.
9.
Breathing the air in Mumbai, India for just
one day, is equivalent to smoking 2.5 packs
of cigarettes.
10.
And finally, there are more plastic flamingos
in the United States than real ones.